if there's one thing the Walking Dead
has proven over its run it's that no one
is safe from Lori's disturbing demise to
the gruesome fates of Abraham and Glenn
the AMC series has made it pretty clear
that in Robert Kirkman zombie apocalypse
the stakes are high one character that
has felt untouchable through all of it
has been Rick Grimes from the day he
woke up in that Georgia hospital Rick
has beaten the odds quite severe on the
heels of Cole's passing though it looks
like this show is on the verge of an
overhaul and now has been reported that
after season 9 Andrew Lincoln will leave
this series that made him a household
name so how might the end of the Rick
tighter ship impact the show moving
forward he is what Lincoln's departure
probably means for The Walking Dead new
leadership viewership for The Walking
Dead has been on a steady decline since
the show hit its peak in season five and
one of the reasons maybe Rick himself
over the past few years we've watched
his wreck repeatedly led the group from
one new home to another only to find out
the humans are more dangerous and
zombies along the way he's had some very
repetitive struggles with morality that
saw him make terrible choices then
redeem himself and eventually do it all
over again at this point it's pretty
predictable and some viewers also think
it's a little boring
Rick's primary motivation to stay in
charge has always been to protect Carl
so now that he's out of the picture it's
only natural that the sheriff might
finally step aside and let someone else
take points and that person might just
be Daryl Dixon AMC may be positioning
the crossbow wielding motorcycle
enthusiast to take over as top dog
reports say that actor Norman Reedus is
negotiating a sweet new deal with the
network that will give him top billing
for the series as a whole
daryl has long been a reliable capable
fan favorite on the show and since he
never appeared in Robert Kirkman's
comics the sky's the limit as to what he
can achieve of course it may be hard to
imagine how a character has been so
quiet and restrained for all this time
can start barking orders at everybody
but maybe he'll be the kind of guy who
leads by example instead fractured group
as the bloody battle between wrecking
negan came to its long-awaited
conclusion a new conflict emerged Maggie
Daryl and Jesus had formed a secret
alliance with the end goal of taking
down negan against Rick's wishes
to do what he did
we're shown to Alexandria and his allies
will be dealing with a fair share of
internal conflict in the coming episodes
with negan smiling and swearing on the
sidelines what role he'll played during
the Civil War remains to be seen but it
may be the catalyst of both Rick and
Maggie leaving since lauren cohan is
expected to leave the series in the
coming season as well with both of the
show's de facto leaders on their way out
and the negan still around causing
everyone problems we can expect the
culmination of this growing family feud
to be pretty spectacular and les new
bodies in the finales final moments
after showing leniency to negan and his
saviors Rick spoke of a new beginning
diehard comic fans know that means a new
threats is probably on its way next
season is expected to begin with a
two-year time jump and if it's anything
like Kirkman's a new beginnings comics
arc we can expect to meet the whisperers
sooner than later negan's violent acts
push the envelope of what can be done on
TV but his brutality may be nothing
compared to these people and their
introduction might just give negan the
opportunity to redeem himself
if season 9 does end up delivering on
the Civil War storyline and may be
possible that negan could prove himself
useful is it possible that negan could
team up with Rick or even Daryl once
these whisperers made themselves known
stranger things have happened
lone wolf another consequence of the
potential new beginning storyline is
that Michonne may start doing it alone
again in the new episodes in the comics
following the all-out war with negan
Michonne pretty much ran away from the
group to live out in Oceanside
while that sounds like more of a Carol
move it's not out of the question that
was shown could separate herself from
the rest of the Alexandria gang if Rick
is gone after all when we first met her
the only company she kept was a pair of
jawless walkers Rick is the first person
she's been romantically involved with
since the trauma of losing a boyfriend
and son their relationship added new
layers to the series giving them both a
welcomed sense of hope and purpose
without Colter mother or Rick to comfort
we might just see Michonne trading a
samurai's sword for a fishing rod after
all rebrand time after 8 seasons a lot
of viewers have tuned out simply because
there's only so much misery and grief a
person can take from their entertainment
the network may finally be catching on
to that because losing Kohl didn't just
sparked the events that transpired in
the back half of season 8 it
sets up the walking-dead for a major
rebranding brighter Scott Gimple told
The Hollywood Reporter
story-wise we knew we were going to be
here it allows for a new voice to be
telling new stories and really resets
the show in a lot of ways the voice he's
referring to is incoming showrunner
Angela Kang who will take over in the
new season in Paul's pivot from
showrunner to chief content officer is
not only a change of the guard behind
the camera it alludes to a new look feel
and strategy for the long-running series
you have to write a character point of
view as if you absolutely believe that
to be the truth so perhaps the new
creative direction will also mean the
mood will swing in a direction more fans
can stomach every week will say thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you're there take
[Music]